the United Kingdom has agreed to provide
Storm Shadow missiles to Ukraine but
what is a Storm Shadow missile and why
will it make a difference to this
campaign
Storm Shadow missiles were first
invented around the mid 90s it's a joint
proposition between the UK and France
there are long-range missile designed to
hit static targets that are very deeply
fortified and high value targets they
had to be high value because the Storm
Shadow is quite an expensive bit of Kit
it does go 300 kilometers but it costs
about 2 million pounds a copy but it's
got a special Warhead in it a double
Warhead the first Warhead breaks open
the Target and the second Warhead goes
through the Gap to blow up the Target
and that means it can go through between
two and four meters of concrete it's
also very capable of flying at very low
level using train masking and a whole
host of electronic warfare capabilities
most of which we can't talk about
publicly unfortunately it's also very
heavy weighs about 1300 kilograms that's
more than a weight of a small car and
therefore there are only certain
aircraft they can carry that sort of
weight and deliver it to a Target but it
will provide a game-changing capability
for the Ukrainian military
president zielinski has been really
clear that he needs the West's weapons
he needs short-range weapons to equip
their troops on the front line but he
also needs to Target Russian Logistics
and ammunition stores which are often
quite some way behind the front line now
Confidence from the West about whether
these weapons could be used to Target
within Russian soil has limited the
West's appetite to provide longer range
weapons but as the West has got more and
more confidence in Ukraine's ability to
use the weapons as they are requested by
the West so they've started to go to
artillery which goes 20 miles America's
provided high miles at 50 miles and now
it looks like the West particularly
around the UK is prepared to go out to
300 kilometers and that's a significant
difference and a significant risk for
the UK taking that big decision on
behalf of the West
thank you
the initial Russian response has been
somewhat muted they're trying to find
some adequate response but in reality
it's very limited what Russia has
available to do quite apart from
escalating to nuclear conflict which
most parties thinks is almost
impossible to envisage that that will
happen so the most likely outcome is
Russia would want to throw more
resources into the Ukraine war but
actually it's thrown almost everything
at it since January as it's conducted
its own spring offensive so in reality
we've seen an uptick in the number of
cruise missile strikes of drone attacks
but Russia is absolutely paranoid at the
moment about the forthcoming Ukraine
offense and therefore it's massive Focus
outside back moot has been on defense
particularly to the east of zaparita
where we've seen 120 kilometers of
trench lines Dragon's Teeth which we
haven't seen since World War II that is
the focus of Russia's attention at the
moment